[Music]
so I got some good news and I got some
bad news
que pasa oh good news okay
you like the game is final is bad I like
good news bad news good news ever better
play a swine another good news before
you can then come back to us no sandwich
like that I don't then alright we're
gonna steal the good cos KZ said face
sandwich and some bad news
okay so these things it's like the good
I mean the bad is replacing the good
okay so good news
UFC 249 yeah there is going it's like
they're gonna they're gonna have this
fight while you're doing and it's in a
private island supposedly so says watch
know why he was able to obtain a private
island so that they can continue to fly
international fighters into it because
the problem with holding it in the
States or any other country there's like
a bunch of loss but if you guys own
Island you can keep flying in all these
fighters and they can keep up with all
the fights yeah but what if somebody's
sick
don't screen them they gotta see doctor
yeah so there are you saying like we're
gonna pre test and test and post test
and test and test everything right and
it's like it's like woo is happening
UFC's come back but then here comes the
bad news Disney is a parent company of
ESPN which was gonna be showing the
fights and Disney said nope you're not
gonna do it good Mickey so now it's
indefinitely postponed whoa they would
have been cool like before they got the
I'll in and like what the [ __ ] well it
would have been nice to tell them before
they got the island and everything right
you know we're just trying to like move
multiple pieces at the same time the
most Chinese people I know
in terms of finding loop you know hand
tight yeah just like him like pulling
[ __ ] together and how resourceful he is
I'm like damn this was real and he's
gonna wait for any higher up the Talmud
I feel like that's all successful people
like the ability for them to like how
much they push to get something done
it's [ __ ] crazy yeah holla source
that's why I realize I'll tell you like
why my buddy Joe is so sick
like I was like oh this is why he's such
a mega millionaire because even the way
he approached the charity in the mask
[ __ ] I was like I can't even think like
this like he was able to convince
retailers to stop selling it to the
public and then he in turn got the
government involved to buy the stock at
retail price while we were able to
access the stuff so we can sell it to
the hospital I mean we can get what we
bought and give that to the hospitals I
can't even convince the parking
attendant that I did come in within two
hours and I lost my ticket you cannot
pay the full price no I always get
penalized I gotta pay the $30 I'm like I
trust my only Park you fight a half an
hour yeah it's [ __ ] crazy
losing the ticket bart lewis i mean
learn your lesson yeah but that's just
the level of why these guys are so mega
like they get [ __ ] done like people
don't know the the moving pieces for me
I'm like oh that's tough maybe I can go
and watch Netflix or something later and
I who would think to buy an island right
well Rona happened time guess we're not
doing JK news yeah yes it's the free
vacation guys the JK island that we saw
flights now but we made this shoot
happen though and you know me and you we
were working on this for like three
hours you're Dana wait three weeks for
Dana Brown hey but that's why we're not
[ __ ] UFC but I weren't taking films
you gotta meet but possible full
sandwich good news then it might be
khabib finally fighting yeah because
initially this fight wasn't gonna have
compete regionally so they've been
trying to make this fight khabib and
Tony Ferguson for it is the fifth time
right so they've been trying to make it
happen for a long time already and
they're like okay this fight is cursed
it's never gonna happen MMA guys we're
gonna allow it they finally made it
they're healthy they're gonna fight and
then freaking rolling it happens so all
the MMA fans have been whining on
Washington fire all this really isn't
gonna
happen and then when they got canceled
and dynamite was at 2:49 that happened
no matter what reason just engag he was
gonna fire Ferguson because kaboom is
stuck in Russia and then some of the MMA
fans like me who really want to Seifert
like Ferguson versus khabib is more
important than 249 and so and gay Chi is
a really tough dude and so we all know
it as possibility that case you can beat
Ferguson or even if Ferguson wins he's
gonna be injured some sort we're not
gonna see the hundred-percent Ferguson
where is hundred percent could be but
which is what everyone wants to see so
now that long time coming so now that
this whole thing is is like squashed I'm
really hoping that everyone could stay
healthier so we could see that fight
because that will be the light weight
fight of the century so here's some
photos here's Dana in case you don't
know what you look like when a madman
yeah this is uh this was the fight that
was supposed to happen right the one
that you were just talking yes could be
vs. Ferguson and then this is the one
that was going to happen when they
announced that I know I know it doesn't
have the same like I don't know it's not
I don't want to I don't care to see that
by his name hmm
kgs probably like he sounds like the
consolation prize yeah I don't know the
craziest thing about this fight it's
like they've always said it was cursed
because like when they first put the
fight together one of them didn't make
weight or whatever the other one got
sick the next time and third time around
like one of them got injured the fourth
time you know it's like so it's always
something happened but it was like a
personal issue that happened but this
time you know this whole the whole you
know virus thing happens and it's like
who could have seen this coming
yeah being the reason why 4/5 times
fight goes by titian even one of them
they were both healthy and they made it
to the to the weigh-ins and the fire
there during the press conference and
then one of them trips over some chords
and tears all 20 Ferguson like he just
he trips over some course he [ __ ]
tears every ligament in his knee on the
walk yeah and they're like he passed the
training camps I need freaking rips and
he picking on some cords because what
would happen if it does no I mean maybe
the
cause the Rona give you another I don't
want it it's like final destination
excavated version of this that the
aliens are coming that's up what they're
supposed to this month what alien just
know everyone wait woody why turn into
dad you guys don't you guys haven't seen
the whole like memes
yeah they're saying that April yeah in
April they're saying that aliens are
gonna finally remove themselves like
well the colors know why it's just a
meme ah I wanted some like actual
conspiracy I'm like I'm ready Joe I'm
ready
no all right they're like did they're
preparing for the Rona's and then after
the Rona's it's the alien invasions yeah
which is the rapture back to the thing
that I was saying yep everyone thinks
the rapture is always gonna happen and
it never does y2k 2012 because I feel
like we ran out cuz if you think about
it right like ours to [ __ ] that our
grandparents went through that probably
felt more like the rapture than anything
that we're going yeah world war one
world war two or legs right after yeah
all that kind of [ __ ] and like man all
there's crazy diseases and all that [ __ ]
yes for Great Depression [ __ ] all
that our recession was not the Great
Depression no I barely felt the pressure
was so bad people were giving kids away
because they couldn't feed on right like
we don't have that [ __ ] here really
and then our World War three that's
happening right now is not the world war
two that pace no it's like online in
Chico sorry exactly I already to steaks
oh no we can only take one [ __ ] thing
an egg so what are we gonna do you know
ya know the Cold War like our parents
like they they they had to [ __ ] worry
about nuclear threats and destination
and you give in second they had that in
school so you know we have fire alarms
and I what to do they had like the
atomic bomb
I'm just like [ __ ] it what did that
little bit they don't need small we kind
of have that a little bit like our
version of that because now in schools
they also added the like shooter oh
that's cool
and then like how North Korea is kind of
scaring everyone on the west coast about
like sending their nukes that's true
just a little bit just a little bit yeah
all right back then were sold like
whatever is like fired in our earthquake
drills you're like all right cool no
classes let's just stand outside and
talk to each other for an hour but if
you really really think about like back
in the days where Europe was constantly
fighting or just the world right like if
you lived in the village and you're just
some farmer soldiers gonna come in and
be like give me all your beats and your
daughters yeah I mean like anything just
come in and [ __ ] take the girls and
just leave it's like that's some nutty
[ __ ] and they've been humans have been
doing that for ages I know that's
actually the one fear that I do have
like with this whole being taken away
not be if people invading like other
people's like homes and stuff that
should scare you cause all that personal
attack yeah yeah looters like looting
into our home that's why have you got
guns huh I would be on top of my roof
tools [ __ ] kid comes over try to
throw a newspaper I'm talking about
beats and then she keep you fresh roof
well Steven Joe combined his boy yeah
man like I think that is kind of like a
scary thing that might be real though
like Walking Dead kind of I saw you at
your friend's gunshot yeah Oh Dan just
see him dead on his stories yeah I saw
him on his stories no he was posing no
you know what it's that I wasn't really
trying to go during this crazy time so
you know my buddy he owns a jewelry
store right so you met him too but he
his family got they you know their whole
family owns jewelry stores and you know
his parent
Scot stocked and then basically the guys
put him at gunpoint
tied up their family members and it was
just some they beat his mom it was
horrible like they took millions of
dollars in just like purses jewelry
whatever right and so they knew his name
and his brother's name because they were
stocking the whole family and then
they're like yeah we're so it's all
where's the video footage all this stuff
so he got scared because he just bought
a new house with his wife and like they
just barely got their security equipment
like in it's not even online yet and he
was like Joe like uh you know do you
have that gun you're selling cuz I feel
super and safe and I'm like okay but the
thing with California is I can't just
drop off the gun I have to be there to
transfer it to one so we went there and
then the gun shop was literally like a
seven-hour wait of human beings yeah and
because my buddy is like the manager
there we got kind of a special like
expedient like like thing but what was
happening to is they were on the news
too because you know all the hate crimes
that were happen Asians yeah so a lot of
Asians who never even thought about
owning a gun were like I'm [ __ ] scared
for my family and just like races
violence so I feel like I need to
protect myself so it was that in the
combination of just regular gun owners
who wanted to pick up a mole or just
anything and like I think a lot of
uncertainty made people scared about
what might happen like if a riot happens
because there's no food or whatever like
people are scared of that just being
able to protect themselves yeah that's
crazy so traumatic I know right and that
makes me want a name like my kids stupid
names cuz I don't think you can you can
be mean to people cuz imagine if you
want to kidnap someone right let's say
that's in your names like your son's
name's Donald had a fee they're gonna be
like give me your [ __ ] money Donald
and Daffy and they're gonna feel bad but
they have to know their names to rob
them
I got a change I think Tiger sounds kind
of cool you could give me your money
it's not it flows so they taking taking
taking taking taking taking mine and
take it under that one no no that'd be
funnier it's gonna be the name when it
makes the robber laugh and then it might
not a bad idea
why does it Robert have to know their
name and then that story they knew their
name just name your kid giggles come
buddy giggles
[Music]
[Music]